bester rand den ich jemals hatte das ist
das aller aller aller traum ist das
unternehmen dieses traumgehalt dass
menschen kein essen haben irgendwo und
damit herzlich willkommen hier heute am
mittwoch seiner neuen episode von ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich warum er mich
gerade noch nicht sehen können dass sie
ganz einfach daran
ich weiß auch nicht was für meine leute
falsch gelaufen ist war wieder auf
youtube unterwegs und youtube hat ja
irgendwie und ganz komischen empfohlen
modus wenn wir empfehlen die die
irgendwelche sachen wo die einfach nur
so denkst sind nämlich abstoßen in
meinem fall wurden beispielsweise
gestern nacht um 3 uhr einfach mal
dieses video empfohlen
auf jeden fall war ich dann irgendwie in
so einer schleife drin und kam auch
nicht mehr raus das war es aber dann
auch noch nicht
dann wurden wegen die gänse empfohlen
fragt bitte einfach nicht allerdings
dachte youtube sich dann anscheinend
haye der typ sich unnormal gerne videos
von gänsen an hier hast du noch 1
dort haben zwei personen während einer
live tv übertragung hintergrund einfach
mal ja illegale geschäfte vollzogen
[Musik]
aber gut ich dachte mir dann hey you
tube ihr könnt mich wirklich mal am
arsch lecken letzten zwei wieder nicht
werde freundlich gewesen keinen cent
verdient ihre ich bin dann auf jeden
fall übergegangen auf twitter habe
direkt meine gehirnzellen auf den
nächsten level gehoben nachdem ich zehn
war kann man an zwei händen abzählen wie
häufig fahrradfahren gegangen also
vielleicht so höchstens 15 mal
eigentlich dann bin ich allerdings zum
größten deutschen streamer übergegangen
doch motto zerstört nicht nur regelmäßig
controllern leiden
er hat jetzt auch einen tv-beitrag
bekommen und stern tv war nämlich bei
ihm zu hause doch monte wollte nicht so
direkt wie die steer tv leute wollten
eigentlich wollen nicht ständig vor das
jetzt anfangen zu zocken aber ich habe
gesagt es nicht schon immer erst mal ein
bisschen ab und fangen dann erst an zu
zocken können jetzt erst mal auf die
couch schauen damit den rumlümmeln ich
werde einfach mein ding machen ich hab
noch keinen bock direkt anfangen zu
singen
die stern tv leute kommen extra zum
wollte nach buxtehude gefahren wollen
einfach nur kurz in dem beitrag abdrehen
aber nehmen die ist nicht montes schild
immer erstmal und deswegen sollten sich
die stern tv kameraleute nach hinten
versetzen auf so versetzte ein bisschen
chillen warten bis er wirklich bock hat
angefangen
auf jeden fall haben sich die
kameraleute nicht verpasst diese nie
einfach nicht nach hinten gegangen und
das hat sherlock monte natürlich gesehen
so sieht keinen rückwärtsgang für mich
aus ich sehe euch ja ihr könnt euch da
auf die couch pflanzen die fische ein
bisschen begutachten ich werde jetzt
aber noch nicht direkt anfangen zu sagen
einer legende nach zu urteilen sitzen
die stern tv leute dort noch immer und
begutachten die verschärften dazu ich
mache das immer so schick mir die sachen
immer bei facebook auf mein messenger
account
facebook aber facebook ist auch voll
cool finde ich auch ja ja so da wir
jetzt ja moment das nutzt jeder damit
nicht allerdings rübergegangen zu kevin
ak papa platte und was sein stream
wirklich immer ausmacht ist dieses
harmonische miteinander ja da
wer jetzt in den top 3 ist ist in den
top 3 das stimmt das stimmt und meistens
sind die leute die in irgendwelchen top
10 sind dann auch tatsächlich in den top
also die sülz von kevin gefallen er ist
am besten ach guck mal hier ist doch was
[Musik]
irgendwann war es für mich dann
allerdings zu zeitaufwendig die ganzen
einzelnen clips wo kevin seine kontrolle
zu stellen herauszuschneiden von der
fahrer kurze compilation
mann
da bin ich auf jeden fall übergegangen
zum try max der in letzter zeit
eigentlich nur noch pokémon karten
öffnete und an einer stelle hat er
irgendwie ziemlich krasses pokemon
gezogen rings um mein kopf war
spätestens da lag ich auch schon wieder
am uniklinikum mit dem herzinfarkt ich
krieg das gar nicht hin dass irgendwie
hinzukriegen
vielleicht sollte es nun mal mitkommen
ins uniklinikum packen wir auch direkt
mit einem hinzu nichts trinkt was ich
habe keine korrosion
was ist das denn coca cola
ist ein ganz neues getränk das so
schwarz hat koffein drin davon wird man
fit aber oder mir jetzt sogar noch das 3
max auch ein bisschen mathe nachhilfe
mit den zuschauern gemacht 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 12 10 durch zwei ist zwölf und
das ist monte aufgestanden weil tracks
weil bei monte zu hause schreibt
allerdings sitzen geblieben und ist mit
dem rollstuhl schreibtischstuhl und
holzstuhl kriegs ist auf jeden fall zur
seite gefahren und beim monte über den
zäh und normaler mensch kennt diesen
schmerz führt diesen schmerz und
entschuldigt sich direkt und sein bruder
story solche gegenden kühlakkus holen
aber treu max geht anders vor
er stellt sich denn auch da hin zur
psychologen und so sagen immer so jamann
verliebt sich maximal drei mal im leben
oder sowas aber ich habe mich schon in
über 100 animax verliebt gar nicht
zustimmen mir sind es allerdings keine
anime girls oder irgendwelche tik tok
mädchen irgendwann hatte sie mir also
jetzt immer gezeigt und dann fiel mir
auf dass da so auf ihren schrank eine
art schädel ähnliches etwas war also ein
schädel hat mir so kelek schädel was
back ups befragt bekommt der schädel
herren und man sieht ja dass menschen
schädel hat er ausgegraben auf dem
friedhof wer kennt nicht völlig normaler
montagmorgen achter ist habe ich auch
machen friede und gerade einfach ein
paar schädel aus stilfs mich dann ernst
ticket sie aus ich reite sie aussicht
also wenn man twitch wirklich mit zwei
sätzen beschreiben müsste wäre es
erstens absoluter rage wird alles
mögliche wird er irgendwie zerstört und
leute rasten außen beleidigen rum und
zweitens
intelligenz quotient milch ist
eigentlich sozusagen wechsel von kühl
ich glaub ich miete mir bald man
busfahrt durch ganz deutschland sondern
die ganzen tricks streamer ein und wir
fahren alle zusammen so eine klinik und
dann wird alles mal auf null gesetzt und
wieder neu aufgebaut und vielleicht
lernt kevin daran auch tanzen
[Musik]